karen's in lubbock texas hi karen how
are you
hi dave hi ken it's an honor to speak
with you all
you too what's up um
my question is this i i am in baby steps
four and five and i have a 23 year old
son
he will be going to graduate school in
dallas um in
august and he's going to get a
free scholarship for all the 2 000 of
his graduate school
however i'll be helping him pay for
his rent and when he gets rent there
when he rents
his house he will be having roommates
and if i am asked
to co-sign i know i've heard you say
many times not to
co-sign for somebody when they're
renting for your child
so my question is
what can i do um if i'm asked to co-rent
what other options would i urge to
co-sign what other options would i have
are you paying the route
i'm going to help him he'll probably be
paying some of it that i'm going to pay
um help him with a lot of it do you have
the money
yes i do i'm on baby steps four and five
and
um
he's 23 okay and what's his grad work
he's going to graduate in music
performance
okay is he working while he's in doing
his grad work
yes he will be he's in undergrad he did
a lot of
gigs and um you know
he did a lot of work and he did um he
paid for most of it most of his rent
and um
yeah i paid for minimal of his school so
i won't be paying a whole lot
but the issue is i i'm
just concerned that when he gets a
roommate he doesn't have any credit
or credit cards thank god but if i'm
asked to co-sign for him
the answer is no i would not co-sign for
anyone under any circumstances
the reason i was asking so many
questions i was trying to figure out
where you were in a couple of things on
parallels
so um one of my kids at college
moved into a house with a bunch of other
kids
and a i didn't want his name
or my name uh tied to being liable
for the whole rent if the other goobs
didn't pay their share
right which happens in college
situations all the time
okay yes and so what i did in that case
was i called the landlord talked to him
and i just prepaid
his rent for the year okay no signature
required
uh no lease required that we're he's
liable for the whole thing
because he's not liable for anything his
part's already paid
and i'm certainly not signing anything
yes i
yeah that's what um that's what i i just
wanted to be prepared when that question
arises
so and i don't want to burst your bubble
but i do want you to be thinking about
something and your son
why do you need graduate level work and
performance
in the music business
he his ultimate goal
is to be a professor to get a doctor
okay then that would make sense all
right that's the only reason i can think
you would want to get that
but you certainly don't need it to be a
performer like
the number of performers who have a
graduate degree
that stand on the stage and perform
music is
zero in fact there's a high percentage
of those performers don't even have a
college degree right dave i had a
question there
you know i'm a little old school i i
don't know why
the 23 year old's not able to pay his
rent
a hundred percent i appreciate mom she's
awesome she's amazing
she wants to help clearly this young man
did a great job in college of paying for
most of his college and he has no debt
but at 23 i want my kid if he's going to
grad school i want him paying his own
rent
am i am i an archaic
old no i mean if she no no you're not
that that's preferable and she she's you
know she said he's a hard worker and
he's basically yeah he's
absolutely responsible he's not his
kid's not him right he's not a parasite
so um you know yeah i i think uh but but
to say absolutely zero
you know i might help i might have
helped one of mine in that situation
but my first and best choice for them is
for them to figure out a way to cut
cut their own way through the forest
yeah
you know get get the axe out get the
machete out time for you to do your own
thing baby doll yeah
and uh it's good it's good for that
that's not a bad thing at all